ein komisches völkchen die briten egal
wie gewichtig die situation
es wird gelacht über alles und alle guy
stevens holt comedians wie stephen kass
seit jahren in die schweiz
rainer eigennutz denn alsbald zürcher
habe er wenig zu lachen humor muss für
ihn schwarz sein
aber woher kommt dieser eigentlich
damals bei den öffentlichen
hinrichtungen beim heutigen morgens
haben einige verurteilte einen lustige
rede gehalten bevor sie gehängt worden
aha wir fragen ebenfalls die
schriftstellerin kathrin emely die
engländerin mit schweizer pass schrieb
mit ihrem historischen erstlings staub
und sternenstaub schlagzeile geht um den
britischen humor führt sie das empire
ins feld und dessen untergang
urvertrauen galgenhumor
was denn nun
naja vielleicht sind diese die
sprichwörtlichen zwei seiten derselben
medaille
oder war drehen wir das rad der zeit
nicht ganz so weit zurück
in den 1970 er und 80 er jahren schrieb
die komikertruppe monty python mit
bitterböser satire geschichte so auch
mit
inspiriert wurde monty python von spike
mehligen der als vater der modernen
britischen komödie geht billigen war
traumatisiert aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
zurückgekehrt und fand dank humor und
der legendären grund schon wieder hallt
über das schlimmste zu lachen britische
cleverns wenn es wirklich schlecht geht
ist es das beste zu versuchen und die
lustige seite zu sehen
denn sonst stehst du es vielleicht nicht
durch das ist eine option
vage ausgedrückt liebst cleverness
zeichnet die briten auch stolz aus
gepaart mit selbstironie austeilen und
einstecken
letzteres musste prinz charles als er
dem von ihm verehrten spike wenigen
nicht persönlich zum lebenswerk
gratulieren konnte
respektlosigkeit oder viel eher
wertschätzung auf jeden fall gerät eine
solche pointe keine briten in den
falschen hals
jedes mal wenn ich ihn sehe geht mir das
herz auf
er hatte gleich um die ecke gewohnt wo
ich aufgewachsen
herzhaft lachen können die briten selbst
über den sensenmann sogar als monty
python mitglied graham chapman starb
hielt sein freund und kollege john
cleese am humor fest in großbritannien
macht man sich so freunde und in der
schweiz
hier zählen zurückhaltung pietät
seriosität in der schweiz verfolgt man
weder raum noch spricht man schlecht
über andere in der öffentlichkeit
jemanden zu beleidigen
macht man in der schweiz nicht heiß in
großbritannien gibt es diesbezüglich
mehr freiheit
denn ob real oder normal wir alle sind
nur menschen übers leben kann man weinen
oder lachen
je nach wahl